hey folks Danny here and welcome to a
very special week here on GameSpot calm
this week is a 20th anniversary of the
site's launch and to celebrate we've
produced a bunch of articles and videos
looking back at the games memories and
people that made up the past two decades
on GameSpot today I'm starting the ball
rolling with games not just any games
but the best games over the past 20
years tens of thousands of games have
been reviewed here on GameSpot but only
a handful have received our coveted Game
of the Year award some of these are
classics some of these is not so much
but each of these games made enough of
an impression on the site staff at that
time to be immortalized on today's list
we got 20 years to cover so let's get
the ball rolling
GameSpot's first ever game of the year
just barely scraped in released on new
year's eve of 1996 the game wasn't even
reviewed by GameSpot until late January
but some have still managed to grab the
game of the year
earning a score of nine point six out of
ten Diablo was the first and a storied
series of action role-playing games of
course this was back in the days when
GameSpot only reviewed PC games so
Resident Evil Mario 64 or Crash
Bandicoot didn't even stand a chance but
it did be that competition on the PC
from games like sieve - Duke Nukem 3d
and the original quake 1997 was a
wonderful year for console games at
games like Final Fantasy 7 Goldeneye and
more but the game that took home the big
prize was cave dogs outstanding
breakthrough realtime strategy game
total annihilation a wonderful mix of
old and new the series has been in
hibernation for an eternity now but back
in 1997 it was a staple of an
increasingly popular or TS genre it's
9.3 review beating out such PC classics
as MDK tomb raider 2 and the second
quake not a lot of quake fans on the
office back then I guess in 1998
GameSpot launched its sister site video
game spot to cover the ever-expanding
console market and so for a few years
the site gave to Game of the Year awards
so while the PC side of the site placed
the ribbon on possibly the best point
and click game of all time in Grim
Fandango one young reviewer on the
console side had the goal to give at the
site's first ever 10 out of 10 to a
Nintendo 64 game a game that would
eventually win the site's console game
of the Year award for 1998 through a
viewer a young Jeff Grossman the game
The Legend of Zelda Ocarina
time 1999 saw another ten at a ten win
for the console game of the year one of
the best fighting games of all time Soul
Calibur while a young Greg Kasavin who
would later go on to design a bunch of
wonderful games in his own right handed
an 8.4 to the eventual winner of the PC
gaudy the timeless online role-playing
game
EverQuest 2000 is a bit of an
embarrassing one to be honest and home
to the only 10 at a time I think we'd
all agree shouldn't have been given a 10
at a 10 even some of the people who
worked on the site back then would agree
that this was a bit of a Mis score but
sadly we cannot change the past and the
first console game of the year of the
millennium went to the ten out of ten
earning Chrono Cross yeah I know much
more respectable was the PC winner in
The Sims a series that would go on to
sell well in excess of 125 million units
over the course of its lifetime 2001 was
the final year GameSpot gave a 2
separate Game of the Year awards the PC
side awarding throwback first-person
shooter Serious Sam the first encounter
the coveted prize beating at games such
as Max Payne and civilizations 3 while
perhaps the best 2d to 3d conversion in
videogame history the groundbreaking
Grand Theft Auto 3 walked away with the
console honors even beating at Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater 3 which grabbed a 10
out of 10 earlier that same year 2002
saw a unified award go to the GameCubes
metroid prime garnering in its standing
nine point seven review score to boot
beating out a suite of similarly lauded
games like Grand Theft Auto Vice City
battlefield 1942 the first Splinter Cell
morrowind and Jedi Knight 2 the
following year saw the second game of
the Year award for Nintendo struggling
console this time by a cel-shaded little
boy The Legend of Zelda Wind Waker
picked up on line point three and top
honors in the same year we saw Star Wars
Knights of the Old Republic I've been in
a few Game of the Year debates during my
five years here at GameSpot but even I
can't imagine how long the deliberations
must have been back in 2004 this was the
year of GTA san andreas Burnett 3 halo 2
The Sims 2
Metal Gear Solid 3 kotor 2 doom 3 farcry
and would you believe it half-life 2 so
what game could possibly be that such
stiff competition I mean it would have
to be one of the best games ever made as
genre-defining classic whose effect can
still be felt over a decade later so
maybe an HD remix of Chrono Cross
not kidding it was only bloody World of
Warcraft 2005 so the console snatched
back the gaudy after a 12-month
sabbatical and you know what for a
console that sold so badly the GameCube
has a bunch of Game of the Year awards
on GameSpot the latest and final being
the outstanding Resident Evil forum the
halfway point in this list witnessed the
arrival of the HD gaming generation so
it's no surprise that the poster boy of
the world's most popular console took
home the biggest honors 2006 as Gears of
War was the first Xbox exclusive to win
the award beating at stiff competition
from oblivion and The Legend of Zelda
Twilight Princess the following year was
a real barnburner for Game seeing the
launch of call of duty 4 modern warfare
halo 3 Bioshock Assassin's Creed on
portal but it was good ol Nintendo who
grabbed the honors again in 2007 with
the outstanding Super Mario Galaxy the
first hand out of 10 in seven years
Grand Theft Auto 4 failed to take home
the big prize in 2008 in fact it was the
second perfect score of that same year
in Metal Gear Solid 4 guns of the
Patriots which did taking home the big
prize over a multitude of other classics
including fall a three and left for dead
2009 was a year of the classic sequel
with modern warfare 2 uncharted 2 left 4
dead 2 and Assassin's Creed 2 but it was
a brand new game one that spawned its
very own sub-genre that took home the
Gotti From Software's Demon Souls to
come the biggest prize in gaming in 2009
Rockstar may have been bitter about
losing it to mgs4 in 2010 but they got
theirs 2 years later with a game of the
Year award for the outstanding cowboy em
up
Red Dead Redemption similarly Bethesda
who may have hoped to win big back in
2006 with oblivion that game losing it
to Twilight Princess but in 2011 they
finally got the reward with its sequels
Skyrim taking home the 2011 game of the
year by the smallest of margins I was on
the call during the deliberations that
year one that went into the wire against
Valve's portal 2 and while 2011 s game
of the year went to a massive game in
which players can easily spend hundreds
of hours 2012's went to a much shorter
experience that game company's journey
had such an impact on the staff it betta
games like Halo 4 Far Cry 3 Borderlands
2 and Dishonored for the site's top
honors 2013's game of the year went to a
handheld game for the very first time
legend of zelda a link between worlds
captivated the site stop so much it
managed to win game of the year ahead of
Grand Theft Auto 5 BioShock Infinite and
The Last of Us it's fair to say
throughout the years there's been a lot
of Zelda fans at GameSpot the next
winner would have been a shock to anyone
at the start of the year but Middle
Earth shadow of Mordor managed to be one
of the most surprisingly fun games of
2014 there was a lot of internal
deliberation over which it or Dragon Age
Inquisition should take home the trophy
but in the end the emergent glory of the
Nemesis system was just too fun to turn
down and so we reach last year 2015 an
incredible year for gaming where half a
dozen games could easily have picked up
the prize in a less competitive year but
as it turns out fallout 4 blood-borne
rocket League and Metal Gear Solid 5 all
had to make way for the incredible final
chapter in the story of Geralt of Rivia
The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt an independent
game out of Poland was GameSpot's game
of the year in 2015 so that was every
game that's one game of the year over
the past two decades on GameSpot calm
I'm sure there are some you agree with
on some you don't but this is just a
small sliver of all the games we've
played review done adored over the past
20 years here on GameSpot since 1996
games have exploded into new genres and
new worlds we never could have imagined
back in 1996 it's been an incredible
ride so here's the 20 more